pole dancing people it's back it never
left I guess and organizers of the world
pole sports championships want to reform
pole dancing to make it respectable
enough to be in the Olympics and now I'm
pretty sure you're familiar with what
pole dancing is but here's a slightly
cleaned up version that could end up in
the Summer Games one of these days
people think so many different things
yeah it's changed when I started ten
years ago I'd speak to someone in there
and I'd say oh you know I teach pole and
the first thing they would say is oh
you're gonna dance for me at the World
Championships for full sports in London
athletes from ten years old to over 60
are here to compete and change attitudes
like gymnastics competitions the
emphasis here on levels of technical
difficulty and flawless execution no sex
appeal okay that obviously does take
some level of athletic skill and the
Olympics has done some odd things lately
they've gotten rid of wrestling they've
gotten rid of baseball so there might be
room for pole dancing as crazy as that
sounds
is this is pole dancing an Olympic sport
do you will you get on a pole and train
for 2020 I've been on a pole and I would
represent this great nation no one wants
to see that I do think there is as
you've said a certain level of
athleticism that is required of this you
know I've I've seen many a pole dancer
on many a continent I'm just saying yeah
and they work hard for that money they
you know I do think however that they
have to take away a certain I won't say
an essential part of pole dancing is the
sexuality or the sensuality of it yeah
but they are kind of trying to strip
that up strip that away pun intended to
make this more a respectable sport yeah
and so even though there is the
athleticism there's the argument that
Tim if you have to change so much of its
very nature to let people perceive it in
this light may not work do you have to
totally D sex
by it to make it work because we have
plenty of that you know you look at
women's tennis it's so based in they
it's all the pretty women that everyone
seems to care about right we've if you
have to do that version of pole dancing
yeah there's just a 10 year olds right
Paul you know 10 year old young age for
the pole yes but I think I mean there
are so many stupid Olympic sports
there's no reason to sit like there are
just as many sports in the Olympics that
are dumber than pole dancing I totally
archery is like what are just hard I've
done archery thinks there's just dancing
she's doing archery what else do you do
the list is long and distinguished or
actually not that distinguished ball
dancing there's like a future to it like
after they were like with archery once
the Olympics are over what are you gonna
go archer somewhere else there's use a
bow and arrow to get out you would mean
you you're killing deer and you have
venison for dinner so you already did
you literally York City you don't know
what people are doing
zombie apocalypse you'll be you'll be
wanting to hang out with me and I'll be
able to distract the zombies there's
what's that guy's name from Walking Dead
if he didn't know how to use that bow
and arrow would he have been able to do
all that he's done to true I think that
might have been a fictional portrayal
but I'm not sure is that but Paul the
answers have some points where they can
work after the Olympics they can make a
living for themselves yeah it should be
it should be the other way around it
should be a way to get the ladies off
the pole in the clubs is to say hey if
you train hard right you could represent
your great nation ironically because the
girls that are doing this in the clubs
and in the strip clubs that are giving
lap dances a lot of them are putting
themselves through college they're
actually making a lot of money I think
it's very empowering for women actually
while the people that are doing Olympic
stuff you know they're not getting paid
and there's all these stories about how
all these people win Olympic gold and
then come home and they're and they're
broke and don't know what to do with
their life and you want to talk about
endorsement deals can you imagine when
the hostler Club gets to put on their
marquee that a gold medalist pole dancer
is dancing tonight yeah there's a lot of
money to be made in that people would
pay cover for that yeah you would pay
cover wouldn't you yeah what yeah I pay
cover for whatever like baby fat and on
you know on those jeans and they could
like clap their butts with it
there's so many more uses I die I'm
endorsing this kid for the Olympics
absolutely would finally oh my god
advertise all in big sport love it
alright well I'm pretty sure I know it
Shawn is next YouTube video will be